après le démantèlement du camp de saint
denis le 17 novembre dernier une partie
des migrants a été accueilli au centre
des mortes mais de versailles
l'association cité caritas et la société
ic i sécurité ont pris en main le centre
le dispositif a été mis en place en cinq
jours seulement
ici c'était vagues rouges qui étaient là
avant et ils sont partis donc le 12 ils
ont quitté les lieux donc nous on a
récupéré un site qu'on a repris de zéro
et en cinq jours on a on va essayer de
faire le maximum pour m pour tout mettre
en place pour accueillir les migrants
qui arrivent et le 17 c'était un petit
peu innovant comme façon de faire on a
mobilisé tout le monde y compris un
petit groupe de personnes hébergées
tibétaine qui nous a aidés à faire un
nettoyage à monter les lie près de 150
personnes sont accueillies sur place
dont 112 ont été prises en charge suite
à l'évacuation du camp de saint denis
on a un public essentiellement afghans
avec divers situation administrative
il y en a qui sont pas loin d'obtenir le
statut de réfugié donc d'autres qui
viennent d'arriver pour lesquels il faut
tout faire et puis une population jeune
dont il s'agit est rentré de paris
moi je dois quand même le premier en a
pris deux ans maintenant j attendais
pour doc au moin té de ce jour qu'a-t-on
sur place et les migrants sont nourris
logés et accompagné au programme
démarches administratives et cours de
français le mardi et le jeudi
en matinée on a des bénévoles du secours
catholique qui viennent et qui est de
l'est
les migrants qui veulent apprendre le
français c'était très très demandeur à
leur arrivée une première étape pour le
centre d'hébergement d'urgence des
mortes mais qui se veut durable
objectif réorienter les migrants vers
d'autres centres adaptés